it's very simple technology but very
laborious and very interesting that it
occurred here in South America and other
parts of the world and they made them
the same in Mesopotamia Egypt North
America Mexico all the similar
technologies I mean there's various ways
to make a reed boat but they pretty much
make it the same way it's important
historically that we show that these
boats can float more than a couple
months at sea and then show the
distances that these boats could have
traveled this is more than an adventure
this is a scientific experiment
I love the these adventures and I
especially like mixing science and
history and other things in an
expedition so this to me sums up
everything that I like is it's been a
burning desire to actually really make a
good attempt across the whole Pacific
because no one is no one has done it in
a reed boat and and this will be the
longest reed boat in history